do you speak french no no english
the
the syrians
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
all right so i'm welcome guys um
so i had to start the vlog a little bit
late
uh because i didn't have my camera
batteries blah blah blah but so far the
van is nearly full
um and we're gonna head off to um i'm to
head off to cali today and somebody's
calling me so i got to
just went for brother uthman both man's
um they're picking up the last orders
the van is full packed down inshallah
i just booked uh the ferry um because i
was so busy i totally forgot i just
booked it now we need to leave in a
couple of hours as you guys can see i
look like a bit of a chav
uh with my
uh yes first time i'm wearing
um attractive bombs in a long time but
they're comfortable
brothers and sisters as you can see how
brother of mine looks mashallah you know
we're definitely getting that double
checkup i don't know yeah
[Applause]
the car's on the floor
we're half an hour
can you move your hand from your face
please huh can you be more professional
basically half an hour
[Music]
foreign
that's right all right what's that
that's the shower so you shovel while
you're in the toilet
we're gonna go to somewhere called roger
cilandro
it sounds a bit like mexico but it's not
we are in france
yes so i'll see you guys soon we're
going for breakfast brother of mine rice
bro
[Music]
let's get he's getting them
carbohydrates going on
[Music]
can you give us updates what we're doing
that's my lunch
and dessert
a
[Music]
one of the refugee camps we're going to
distribute the goods
what's your name
these guys have been building a kitchen
where they can cook some food okay
brothers this is what we're gonna do now
we're gonna distribute everything in the
vanilla
all right guys we just finished the
distribution
um gave all the clothes and the blankets
because this side of the camp needs that
um
but the pasta and etc we're going to
take it to another camp
as soon as itv finished this interview
over there we're going to head off
inside let's go
oh this is flood
so this is not like they use it or like
usually i talk about this
they're living here since ramadan and
then he's given us the permission to go
into his house to look at the state of
how he's living
so the brother literally been living
here since ramadan
um him his wife and his four children so
it's five of them so six of them sorry
six of them but four children and his
wife and himself is living here since
ramadan three months and the saddest
thing that they said he said to me
is one meal so
whatever he was eating for iftar that
was his suhur as well okay when you ask
them what they needed what did they just
say
they don't have nothing let's start with
that literally nothing and i asked him
what do you need the most he said to me
i need musa and it's quran i need books
and it has to be muslim so i can teach
you know what
one thing to bring is god
all right
they invited us to eat some chicken with
them
i'm sure they needed more than us
and also i came to them and said what
are these both you know we've got around
here and basically they're mastered this
is where they agreed
look at these guys
he's got like a chicken shot
basically ali just
took a bike and he's right at this draw
he's trying to ride a bike
pink is my favorite color always has
been they have a clinic here and they're
treating people
just finish praying salah
and spawn over look at this bro
they have nothing
so they still have their trust in allah
whereas we have everything
but when it comes to salah we
we feel like we're going to give our
life or something
take a picture
look how happy it is
we are here
to have some awkward
we're gonna have some food we have an
air all day the fish that we had that
was it yes
so we're gonna go ahead
and tell you where to get to brothers
sisters we just woke up we're gonna go
to the dunkirk refugee camp where the
main syrians are there and other people
gonna distribute food today and our
target for the next two days is gonna be
to build a proper masjid and a uh little
clinic inshallah we are at this dunk
camp
uh this is where mainly a lot of
refugees are
as you can see
hello
what's your name
okay guys we're just emptying the van
now this is where the storage is this is
where the cooking happens
um they're gonna be cooking here and
distributing it to the
camp that we was just at
the big ben of france
the guy who made this tower was arrested
for terrorism because therefore it was a
bomb
this is itv
we're on the left and wait there i'm
coming back terry islamic brother is our
second day uh in the camp obviously the
syrians
have been basically evacuated from where
they were yesterday we showed you a
camera the police came and kicked them
out they tear gas them so they're here
and they're building their tent
as you can see behind me and oh yeah
this is specifically for the syrians uh
inshallah a lot of some other people
okay they wanted as well just trying to
be fair together because they've got
that well they've got what they need
to try to find
that's our tyre that's that's how we
drove
they actually
cut in this part and you know to make
enough space for their attention
to here you just came now yes yes
i'm from syria okay we're going to bring
tents you know that comes here
yes
yes okay we're going to be we're going
to bring tents yes we're going to bro
give the pasta to the system man
okay
ask them if they need rice
[Music]
[Music]
today's plan is to basically um
just walk up now at eight
it's about half eight here
uh we're getting ready our first plan is
to go uh we've got some goods in the
band that you still gave us and there's
some good uh
hotel i'm gonna go get that and take it
to the dunk camp to the syrians uh empty
that into the van then with the van
empty van i'm gonna go and pick up
uh
a thousand kilograms of dates for eid
and distribute that type of messages
barely
put the door immigration gonna have to
break in otherwise
you've got two minutes to open the door
sir
if you paid your fines this would have
not happened
sorry bro you know when sisters won't
say
[Laughter]
basically these children i'm just
waiting i'm going to give them some toys
yeah as you can see look at their
beautiful smiles on their faces
and said the syrians who were kicked out
by the police yesterday are basically
kind of starving so um
yeah for those who donated and allowed
us to come here everything that we do
inshallah for the sake of allah you guys
will be rewarded
as you can see brother stacking up the
bread
[Music]
gas putting
[Laughter]
[Music]
you don't have it no no
thank you
that was so i'm sick of explaining it
guys
he he for his breakdown
uh
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
make sure you clean it yeah
[Music]
from
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right foreign so basically this is
the place that they pray in this here
not even there this that's where they
sleep so this is where they pray
and our aim is to inshallah
make this place a master so what we're
going to do is
we're going to try to get machetes and
cut all this down and turn it into a
mushroom something like that maybe
something like that building right there
so this is our aim
to turn this into a masjid there's a
fight
there's a fight kicking off
there's a fight kicking off
okay so this is the syrian camp i just
want to record a bit give me two seconds
this is where they live
see this is where they're living
and this way your donations have come
okay basically this is where that family
lives
we're going to give them a gas
so basically this is where the children
and the ladies
are kept it's like a secure place
uh and we're giving the medication the
medication that was donated to us
if you need quran
give him a quran
go to the back go to the back yeah okay
so guys now we're gonna uh the quran so
we're gonna there's some carpets this is
a masjid we're gonna give the carpets in
here so they can use it
[Music]
okay
okay guys look at their faces look how
happy they were this is what they were
using before
yeah
look at them
look this brother got so happy mashallah
it's beautiful
he was so
happy thank you
i can't come in i can't breathe
you could come inside
this is
i'm from guys
this is how my heart is
yeah
wow i
[Laughter]
yeah yeah and how do you get to your
house well like man's got to drive yeah
but what we've got left we've got some
nappies some women probably open it open
some medication baby food baby food okay
so because there's not many females here
because of security and you know some of
them get raped unfortunately the baby
the children and the women are kept here
this is a safe location so we're going
to give everything that we have the
nappies that you gave
the
female staff the
milk for the babies etc cow and gate you
know how it is
so we're going to give it to them and
after that we're finished we're probably
going to go eat and after we eat maybe
make our way back home but obviously
i've got roads my iphone got jacked
so if some brother um snapchat to you
and this lovely lady will just take her
uh so this is helping us they're from
france how do you say hello
so we left that place because they
changed their mind and we've come here
to eat pizza
hope is hello
is it true you have a really bad
headache in your knee
i haven't really heard it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
excuse me i've got you in 18 minutes
mate yeah
apparently with 23.59 was uh for lori's
not tower park so yeah we've got what
time is it
so no midnight 45 minutes past midnight
i'm gonna go in the ferry i'm sleeping
i'll play
my
favorite that i'm pumping out
all right guys so um
because we missed the ferry
right back um half an hour
i'm gonna be having a bit of a sleep
here in the back of the van
hopefully i don't think i'm some kind of
a refugee
but i need to sleep
i'm too tired
that's my bed
yo what's mine
wake me up in half an hour yeah
peace out well okay
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
ah
[Applause]